你現在感覺得到嗎
也許是此刻穿透窗戶的一束光
溫暖了你的手臂
也許是清晨時分
喚醒這座城市的那個巨大輪廓
對於太陽
我們有一種近乎本能的孩子氣的信任
在我們直覺的認知裡
它是永恆的它是穩定的
就像古希臘神話中阿波羅駕駛的馬車
每天準時升起劃過天際
週而復始永不出錯
這種信任不僅僅是神話
它甚至被寫進了科學最堅固的堡壘裡
在很長一段時間裡
物理學家看著太陽
就像看著一顆完美的柏拉圖式球體
直到20世紀中葉
人類用最優雅的數學公式
建立了一座關於恆星的理論堡壘
我們稱之為標準太陽模型 (Standard Solar Model)
這座堡壘告訴我們
恆星是一座巨大的核融合反應爐
氫原子在核心被擠壓 融合
釋放出光和熱
這一切聽起來如此完美
如此合乎邏輯
這些公式解釋了為什麼夜空中的星星會發光
解釋了宇宙的能量來源
這讓我們感到安心
我們以為我們已經掌握了這團烈火的祕密
但是這座堡壘有一個裂縫
這道裂縫不是發生在太陽表面
而是發生在地底深處
1960年代
在美國中西部的南達科他州
一個深達一千多公尺的金礦坑裡
一位名叫雷戴維斯 Ray Davis 的科學家
正在捕捉一種幽靈
這種幽靈叫做微中子 Neutrinos
根據我們那座完美的標準太陽模型
太陽核心在燃燒時
會釋放出無數的微中子
這些粒子不帶電幾乎沒有質量
它們會像穿過空氣一樣
輕易地穿透太陽穿透地球
穿透你的身體
戴維斯的任務就是去數這些幽靈的數量
如果我們的太陽模型是對的
如果我們真的懂核融合
那麼戴維斯的探測器
應該會捕捉到特定數量的微中子
然而數據出來了
三分之一
只有預測值的三分之一
這個數字像一道冰冷的閃電
擊中了整個物理學界
這就是著名的太陽微中子問題
(The Solar Neutrino Problem)
這不僅僅是一個計算錯誤
這是一個深淵般的恐懼
這意味著兩種可能性
而每一種都令人背脊發涼
第一種可能我們的物理學崩塌了
我們對基本粒子的理解
從根本上就是錯的
第二種可能太陽病了
那顆賦予我們生命的恆星
它的核心可能已經停止了燃燒
這聽起來像是瘋狂的臆測
但在物理上這卻是合理的恐懼
你需要知道微中子是太陽的即時轉播
它們產生後只需要八分鐘
就能穿透太陽抵達地球
但光子不同
光子雖然也在核心產生
但它們被困在太陽內部高密度的迷宮裡
不斷碰撞吸收再釋放
一顆光子要從核心跌跌撞撞地走到表面
可能需要幾萬年甚至十幾萬年
這意味著如果太陽的核心
在今天早上突然熄火了
微中子會立刻消失警報會立刻響起
但我們肉眼看到的太陽
依然會照常升起依然溫暖
因為我們此刻沐浴的陽光
其實是幾萬年前核心燃燒的餘燼
是它遙遠過去的錄影重播
我們可能正守著一顆實質上已經死去的恆星
卻毫不知情
享受著它死前最後的幻影
無論是哪一種
那個完美金球的假象都已經破碎了
我們以為我們認識它
但實際上對於這顆距離我們最近的恆星
我們一無所知
我們需要一雙眼睛
不是在地球上透過厚厚的大氣層仰望
而是飛到它的面前直視它的憤怒
去聽它的心跳
我們需要一位守望者
去確認那團烈火的中心究竟發生了什麼
於是在1995年的冬天
人類將一個重達1.8噸的金屬盒子
送入了一片絕對的虛空
它的名字叫 SOHO
(Solar and Heliospheric Observatory)
太陽與日光層觀測衛星
但我不希望你把它想像成一顆普通的衛星
大部分的衛星像是一群忙碌的蜜蜂
繞著地球低軌道嗡嗡飛行
每一兩個小時就看一次日出日落
但 SOHO 不同它是孤獨的
它離開了地球的懷抱
飛向了距離我們一百五十萬公里之外的
一個特殊點位
拉格朗日點 L1
(The First Lagrangian Point)
想像一下在地球與巨大的太陽之間
有一條看不見的重力鋼索
在這條鋼索上的某一點
太陽巨大的引力與地球微弱的引力
達成了一種奇蹟般的平衡
站在這裡你可以永遠背對著黑暗的宇宙
永遠直視著那顆燃燒的煉獄
沒有黑夜沒有陰影
只有永恆的刺眼的白晝
SOHO 就站在這裡
它就像是一位擁有十二種感官的守望者
全天候調動它那十二台精密儀器
其中三台專注於聽太陽內部的震動
五台負責看日冕與大氣層的細微變化
還有四台則是用來直接捕捉與分析
吹拂而過的太陽風粒子
它執行著人類歷史上最漫長的一次凝視
它的目標不是去欣賞太陽的美
它的目標是要去透視那層耀眼的光球
看到內部的真相
去解開那個讓物理學家徹夜難眠的
微中子之謎
但是你無法直接看到恆星的內部
那裡是不透明的電漿海洋
那麼 SOHO 該怎麼做
它選擇了傾聽
這是一種被稱為日震學(Helioseismology)的技藝
就像地球發生地震時地震波會穿過地核
讓地質學家得以推測地球內部的結構
太陽這顆巨大的氣體球
也在不斷地震動
它像一口被敲響的巨鐘
聲波在恆星的腹地深處迴盪折射反彈
這些聲音我們人類的耳朵聽不見
但在 SOHO 極度靈敏的
麥克森都卜勒成像儀 (Michelson Doppler Imager) 眼中
太陽表面的每一次起伏
都是這首恆星之歌的音符
SOHO 在那條孤獨的重力鋼索上屏氣凝神
它測量著太陽表面數百萬個點的微小震動
將這些震動轉化為聲速的數據
它試圖透過這些聲音的傳播速度
去繪製出太陽內部的地圖
它的密度它的溫度它的自轉速度
SOHO 聽到了太陽內部一個巨大的秘密
它發現太陽的對流層也就是外層
在赤道轉得快在極地轉得慢
但是內部的輻射層卻像一顆剛硬的彈珠
整體同步旋轉
這意味著什麼
這意味著在內外層交界的地方
存在著一個巨大的摩擦帶
科學家給它取了一個名字
差旋層 (The Tachocline)
想像一下兩個巨大的磨盤
在恆星深處互相碾壓
正是這種深層的摩擦
啟動了太陽的磁場發電機
製造出了那些最終會浮上表面
引發風暴的磁力線
SOHO 讓我們第一次看見了太陽表面之下
那條驅動一切的隱形河流
這是一場長達數年的靜默聆聽
地球上的科學家們屏息以待
SOHO 聽到的聲音究竟會告訴我們什麼
是太陽真的病了
還是我們的物理學需要被改寫
這個答案將在它運作的初期
以一種意想不到的方式
為人類的科學史 寫下最戲劇性的一章
當 SOHO 的數據終於傳回地球
經過超級電腦的層層解碼
一張太陽內部的聲速圖被繪製了出來
結果令人震驚卻也令人釋然
SOHO 聽到的聲音
與科學家在黑板上推導出的公式
近乎完美地重疊
它測量到的太陽內部溫度壓力聲速
與標準太陽模型的誤差小於百分之一
這是一個關於清白的判決
太陽是無辜的
它的核心依然在健康地燃燒
沒有熄滅也沒有變異
我們的物理學模型也是正確的
那麼錯的是誰
既然源頭 (太陽) 是對的
接收端 (地球) 也是對的
那麼問題只能出在中間
那個負責傳遞訊息的信差
微中子身上
SOHO 的數據成為了最後一塊拼圖
迫使物理學家接受了一個瘋狂的現實
這些幽靈般的粒子
在從太陽飛向地球的八分鐘旅程中
竟然變身了
它們像變色龍一樣改變了自己的身份
騙過了我們設在地底的探測器
這項發現後來導向了
2015年諾貝爾物理學獎的誕生
因為 SOHO 排除了太陽出錯的可能性
科學家才得以確認
微中子是有質量的而且會發生震盪
SOHO 完成了它的神聖使命
它證明了人類依然懂得恆星的語言
然而命運似乎喜歡開殘酷的玩笑
就在 SOHO 解開了太陽系最大謎題的同時
它自己卻走向了死亡
1998年6月25日
這本該是一個平凡的日子
一次例行的姿態調整
但在距離地球一百五十萬公里的太空中
一個微小的指令錯誤
觸發了一連串災難性的連鎖反應
SOHO 失去控制了
它開始瘋狂旋轉
那隻原本應該死死盯著太陽的獨眼
現在卻像一個醉漢
在黑暗的宇宙中無助地打轉
更糟糕的是它的太陽能板背對了陽光
電力切斷
它無法呼救也聽不到地球的呼喚
在馬里蘭州的控制中心
螢幕上的訊號變成了一條死寂的直線
SOHO 失聯了
對於工程師來說
這不只是失去了一顆價值十億美元的衛星
這像是失去了一位在荒野中探險的朋友
想像一下那裡的環境
沒有了電力的溫暖
SOHO 的體溫開始驟降
零下十度零下二十度
直到它血管裡的血液 聯氨燃料徹底結冰
它變成了一塊在虛空中翻滾的廢鐵
大多數人認為任務結束了
沒有衛星能在那樣的冰封中存活
但有一群人拒絕放棄
這是一場發生在無聲宇宙中的救援行動
其驚心動魄的程度不亞於阿波羅13號
他們首先動用了地球上
功率最強大的深空雷達
阿雷西博無線電望遠鏡 Arecibo Observatory
這隻巨大的耳朵這次變成了喉嚨
它向著茫茫太空發送強力的雷達波
試圖在虛空中照亮 SOHO 的身影
他們在尋找一個微弱的回音
哪怕只是一絲金屬反射的閃光
幾天後他們找到了
在幾百萬公里的深處
有一個微弱的旋轉的亮點
它還在它還沒死
接下來是長達三個月的漫長喚醒
這是一場與熱力學的搏鬥
SOHO 的燃料管線已經凍結
如果加熱得太快
膨脹的液體會撐破管壁
如果加熱得太慢電池就會耗盡
工程師們必須懷著如履薄冰的謹慎
步步為營地發送指令
他們利用太陽能板偶爾掃過陽光的那一瞬間
積攢一點點微薄的電力
他們用這一點點電力去加熱油箱
一度一度地提升溫度 一滴一滴地融化結冰的燃料
這就像是在遙遠的太空中
試圖用體溫去孵化一顆冰凍的心臟
終於在失聯三個月後
SOHO 的心臟重新跳動
它停止了旋轉重新看向了太陽
但是代價是慘重的
它的三個陀螺儀
負責保持平衡的關鍵器官全部損壞了
這就像是一個人失去了內耳的前庭
失去了平衡感
原本註定無法再站立
但在這絕望的時刻
工程師們為它寫入了一套全新的靈魂
他們重寫了 SOHO 的飛行軟體
教導它學會了一種全新的生存方式
不再依賴陀螺儀
而是利用星象儀緊盯著周圍的星星
利用反作用輪的微調來保持平衡
這顆衛星在死亡的邊緣走了一遭
不僅活了下來還學會了新的行走方式
它浴火重生了
而這一次重生
將讓它見證接下來三十年
太陽最狂暴也最壯麗的呼吸
重生後的 SOHO
帶著它那修補過的靈魂
重新凝視著太陽
這一次它不再只是傾聽內部的聲音
它睜大了眼睛
看見了這顆恆星最狂暴的一面
在 SOHO 發射之前
我們知道太陽會有黑子會有閃焰
但 SOHO 讓我們看見了
另一種尺度的恐怖與壯麗
它搭載了一組特殊的儀器
叫做 LASCO 大角度光譜日冕儀
(Large Angle and Spectrometric Coronagraph)
Large Angle and Spectrometric Coronagraph
你可以把它想像成一個
永遠在製造日全食的裝置
它用一個小圓盤
擋住了太陽本體那刺眼的光芒
好讓我們能看清太陽周圍
那層稀薄飄渺的大氣 日冕
透過這副人造的日食眼鏡
SOHO 看見了太陽的呼吸
但那不是溫柔的氣息
那是劇烈的毀滅性的噴嚏
科學家稱之為日冕物質拋射
(Coronal Mass Ejections) CME
想像一下太陽並不是一顆固定的光球
它是一團被磁場線糾纏的電漿
當這些磁場線像橡皮筋一樣扭曲斷裂時
數十億噸的物質會被瞬間拋向太空
在 SOHO 傳回的縮時影像裡
我們看到太陽像是一個憤怒的神祇
向著虛空噴吐出巨大的電漿雲
有時這些雲團是朝著別處飛去
像是一朵綻放的宇宙白菊
但有的時候它會直直地朝著鏡頭衝過來
也就是衝著地球而來
在畫面上那看起來
就像是一個逐漸擴大的光環
迅速吞沒了整個視野
緊接著畫面會出現無數的白色噪點
像是一場暴風雪
那是高能粒子撞擊 SOHO 鏡頭留下的彈痕
請不要以為這只是訊號干擾
這些雪花其實是太陽高能粒子(Solar Energetic Particles)
它們是被爆炸激波加速到接近光速的質子
它們比巨大的電漿雲跑得更快
只需要幾十分鐘就能抵達地球
當你在螢幕上看到這些噪點時
意味著一場肉眼看不見的輻射雨
已經橫掃了太空
對於身處太空站的太空人來說
這些噪點就是致命的警報
請立即尋找掩護
SOHO 成了我們在太空中
最重要的天氣預報員
在風暴抵達前發出最後的警告
除了風暴 SOHO 還看見了更不可思議的景象
它揭示了太陽寧靜外表下的混亂
我們過去以為太陽表面是均勻的
但 SOHO 告訴我們
那裡鋪著一層磁性地毯 Magnetic Carpet
成千上萬個細小的磁場迴路
像燃燒的線頭一樣
不斷地從表面冒出
互相糾纏斷裂釋放能量然後消失
這整層磁性地毯
平均每四十小時就會徹底更新一次
這意味著太陽表面的磁場並不是永恆的
它在不斷地自我更新
我們眼前的這顆恆星
每一刻都是新的每一刻都在重塑自己
而且 SOHO 還挑戰了我們對熱力學的直覺
當它的光譜儀 (UVCS) 掃描那些
噴發高速太陽風的日冕洞時
它看到了一個違反常理的現象
照道理來說在風暴中
輕沙子應該比大石頭飛得快
但在太陽風裡 SOHO 發現
重的氧離子竟然比輕的氫原子
跑得還要快溫度還要高
這就像是看到一顆保齡球比乒乓球飛得更遠
這告訴我們太陽風不是一鍋均勻的熱湯
而是一場精心編排的磁場共振
想像一下有一種看不見的磁波
離子迴旋波
它的頻率剛好對應氧離子的旋轉節奏
這就像你在推鞦韆
只有抓對了節奏鞦韆才會越盪越高
這些波專門挑選了重的離子
把能量優先灌給它們
這不只是風
這是一場精密控制的電磁狂舞
還有太陽海嘯 (EIT Waves)
1997年 SOHO 的極紫外線望遠鏡 EIT
捕捉到了一個震驚天文界的畫面
在一次劇烈的噴發後
一道亮白色的波紋
以每秒數百公里的驚人速度
橫掃了整個太陽表面
那就像是你在平靜的湖面丟下一顆巨石
漣漪瞬間擴散
只不過這道漣漪是幾百萬度的高溫電漿
它的高度超過地球
它席捲的範圍是整個恆星
除了壯觀 這景象解決了一個長久的爭論
那就是太陽表面的活動是局部的 還是全球性的
這道海嘯證明了
太陽的大氣層是一張緊繃的磁力網
牽一髮動全身
當一個點爆炸
衝擊波會沿著這張網傳遍整個恆星
甚至觸發遠在幾十萬公里之外的另一場噴發
彷彿太陽真的震怒了
然而在這個充滿暴力與高溫的觀測中
SOHO 卻意外地捕捉到了
宇宙中最悲傷也最詩意的一幕
SOHO 原本的設計是為了研究太陽
它從未想過自己會成為一名彗星獵人
但在它那廣角的視野中
常常會出現一些微小的不速之客
那是掠日彗星 (Sungrazers)
這些由冰塊和塵埃組成的流浪者
大多屬於一個早已破碎的巨大彗星家族 (克魯茲族彗星)
它們像飛蛾撲火一般
沿著自殺式的軌道衝向太陽
在 SOHO 的 LASCO 鏡頭下
我們看著它們拖著長長的尾巴
從黑暗的邊緣現身
義無反顧地衝進那幾百萬度的高溫日冕中
這是一個關於冰與火的極致對決
有些較大的彗星
能在繞過太陽後倖存
帶著殘缺的身體飛離
像是一個歷經劫難的旅人
但絕大多數都在靠近太陽的那一刻
蒸發殆盡化為一縷青煙
它們在 SOHO 的底片上 留下了最後的身影
更令人動容的是
發現這些悲壯影像的
大多不是 NASA 的科學家
SOHO 是最早將觀測數據
即時公開在網路上的太空任務之一
這意味著
全世界任何人 只要有一台電腦
就能和天文學家同時看到太陽的最新照片
於是一群自稱彗星獵人的業餘愛好者出現了
他們是退休的教師
是天文愛好者
甚至是還在寫作業的中學生
他們分佈在世界的各個角落
日以繼夜地盯著 SOHO 傳回的
那些充滿噪點的黑白照片
他們在尋找那些像素點中
不尋常的移動
這需要極大的耐心和充滿愛的眼睛
這顆造價十億美元
位於太空深處的精密儀器
就這樣與地球上無數平凡人的好奇心
連結在了一起
這五千多顆被 SOHO 記錄下的彗星
每一顆都是人類集體凝視的證明
SOHO 證明了科學不只是冷冰冰的數據
它也是一種共享的溫暖的團聚
三十年
對於浩瀚的宇宙來說這只是一眨眼
但對於人類的航太工程
這是一個奇蹟般的長度
SOHO 原本的設計壽命只有兩年
但它卻堅持了三十年
這意味著什麼
太陽的磁場活動
有一個約為十一年的週期
從平靜到活躍再回到平靜
而兩個這樣的週期
構成了太陽磁極翻轉一圈的
海爾週期 Hale Cycle
大約是二十二年
SOHO 完整地記錄了一個以上的海爾週期
它不僅僅是拍了幾張照片
而是為人類拍下了
一部關於恆星演化的長篇紀錄片
它讓我們看著太陽從沉睡中甦醒
佈滿黑子噴發出狂暴的烈焰
然後又慢慢回歸寧靜
它讓我們理解了這顆恆星的脾氣
它的韻律它的盛衰與輪迴
SOHO 是一面鏡子
透過它我們終於明白了一個事實
我們並不是生活在與太陽隔離的地球上
我們其實一直生活在太陽的大氣層裡
太陽風吹拂到的地方就是太陽的疆界
地球只是這片疆界裡的一顆小石頭
太陽的每一次呼吸每一次顫動
都會撥動我們生活的琴弦
現在 SOHO 已經很老了
它的儀器已經老化
它的太陽能板效率在下降
它依然靠著那套沒有陀螺儀的程式
頑強地在太空中保持平衡
但它並不孤單
在它的肩膀上
新一代的探測器已經接棒出發
2018年升空的帕克太陽探測器 (Parker Solar Probe)
正像伊卡洛斯一樣
一次次衝進日冕的烈火中
試圖觸摸太陽的表面
而2020年啟程的太陽軌道載具
Solar Orbiter
則正在調整軌道
準備從前所未有的上帝視角
俯瞰太陽神祕的南北極
它們飛得更近看得更細
它們將繼承 SOHO 的視線
繼續這場探索
但在那之前讓我們最後一次
將目光投向距離我們一百五十萬公里的虛空
因為在那裡在絕對的寂靜與寒冷中
有一位忠誠的守望者
它傷痕累累卻依然挺立
它背對著黑暗直視著光明
它是 SOHO
它是太陽的守望者
如果你也對這位
在太空中孤獨守望了三十年的巨人
感到敬佩
請幫我們按讚分享這支影片
讓更多人看見這場偉大的太空壯遊
也別忘了在底下留言告訴我們
在 SOHO 揭示的這些太陽面貌中
是那場寧靜的內部震動
那狂暴的太陽海嘯
還是那悲壯的飛蛾撲火
哪一幕最讓你感到震撼
這是我們慢科學系列第四集
我們希望繼續用這樣的節奏
帶大家凝視那些科學史上的偉大瞬間
如果你喜歡這樣的內容
歡迎透過加入會員或留言來支持我們
感謝你的收看我們下次見